web development is the best job in the
world you build on a platform with
nearly 5 billion daily active users all
connected together like the neurons of a
global super intelligent brain a system
that can cure disease eliminate poverty
advance science and stuff like that but
mostly it's used to share memes create
parasocial relationships amplify drama
and most importantly make tons and tons
of money if you want to get into it
you're gonna need to know some stuff
like a lot of stuff in web development
101 we'll take a look at a 101 different
concepts that you'll need to know when
building full stack web apps this is the
internet it's a network of billions of
machines connected together what do you
write to it like mail no a lot of people
use it and communicate i guess they can
communicate with nbc writers and
producers alison can you explain what
internet is it was officially born on
january 1 1983 thanks to the
establishment of the internet protocol
suite which standardized the way these
computers communicate the internet
protocol is used to identify different
computers on the network by assigning
each one of them a unique ip address
these computers can then send data back
and forth with the transmission control
protocol it breaks data into a bunch of
small packets kind of like puzzle pieces
then sends them through a bunch of
physical components like fiber optic
cables and modems before they're put
back together by the receiving computer
you can think of the internet as
hardware but the internet is not the
same thing as the web the world wide web
is like software that sits on top of the
internet where people can access web
pages with the hypertext transfer
protocol what's special about it is that
it gives every page of content a uniform
resource locator or url humans typically
use a tool called a web browser to
access a url where it can be rendered
visually on their screen the browser is
called the client because it's consuming
information but on the other end of that
url there's another computer called a
server it received an http request from
the client then sent a response
containing the web page content these
are called http messages but more on
that later what's interesting is that
every web page has a unique domain name
like fireship.io or example.com a domain
name can be registered by anyone via a
registrar who's accredited by icann a
nonprofit responsible for overseeing
namespaces on the internet when you
navigate to a domain in a browser it
gets routed through the domain name
system that maps these names to an
actual ip address on a server somewhere
dns is like the phone book of the
internet now when you look at a webpage
the actual content you see is
represented by hypertext markup language
most browsers have devtools where you
can inspect the structure of the html at
any time to build your own web page
you'll want a text editor like vs code
an html document is just a collection of
elements where an element is an opening
and closing tag with some content in the
middle like a paragraph and heading it
also has elements that handle user input
like the select and input elements which
are used to build forms in addition
elements can have one or more attributes
to change their behavior for example an
input can have a type like text or
number which the browser will render
differently to collect the appropriate
value but the element that puts the
hypertext in html is the a tag or anchor
it's a link that allows one page to
navigate to a different page based on
its url these elements are nested
together in a hierarchy to form the
document object model or dom from the
root element a web page is split into
two parts the head contains invisible
content like metadata and a title then
we have the body for the main content
that the end user actually sees the
reason we wrap everything in tags is to
give browsers and bots hints about the
semantic meaning of the web page this
allows search engines to display results
properly and also helps with
accessibility for devices like screen
readers that allow anybody regardless of
disability to enjoy the content my
computer reads me the text bro smash
that like button and subscribe one of
the most common elements you'll come
across is div or division to define a
section of the webpage on its own a div
might not seem to do anything and
currently produces this plain black and
white website that begs the question how
do we make this website look cool the
second language you'll need to learn as
a web developer is cascading stylesheets
or css which allows you to change the
appearance of the html elements one way
to accomplish that is with an inline
style using the style attribute on an
element the style itself contains a
collection of properties and values that
change the appearance of the element
like we might make the background color
black and the text color red what we've
created here is an inline style that
will only be applied to this one element
however css cascades which means it can
be applied to multiple elements at the
same time providing better code
reusability another option is to move
our code into a style tag but to make
the code work we'll first need to define
a selector so it knows which elements to
target a selector for example can target
all of the paragraph elements on the
page but that's too broad we can be more
granular by defining a class that style
can then be applied to one or more
elements with the class attribute what's
interesting though is that we now have
classes that apply different styles to
the same element css contains a bunch of
specificity rules that determine which
styles are relevant to an element in a
way that's self-evident and elegant like
a benevolent elephant most often though
we don't use style tags but instead use
an external style sheet which is linked
to the webpage and the head of the
document when it comes to css by far the
most difficult thing to learn is layout
and positioning think of every element
like a box the outside of that box is
wrapped with padding border and margin
the boxes then take up space on the page
from top to bottom some elements like
heading have a display of block by
default which means they take up all
available horizontal space other
elements like image are displayed inline
which means they can line up
horizontally side by side the problem is
that the default position is usually not
desirable it can be changed by
customizing the position property on an
element relative positioning allows an
element to move a certain number of
pixels from its normal position absolute
positioning is similar but the position
values are relative to its nearest
ancestor and then we have fixed
positioning which will keep an element
on the screen even as the user scrolls
away from it because it's fixed to the
entire viewport changing the position of
an element is one thing but one of the
biggest challenges web developers face
is creating responsive layouts users can
access your web page from all kinds of
different screens and it should look
good on all of them css provides a bunch
of different tools to help make this
happen one of which is media queries a
media query allows you to get
information about the device that's
rendering the web page and apply
different styles accordingly but more
importantly it provides layout tools
like flexbox applying display flex
allows the parent to control the flow of
the children to easily create rows and
columns for more complex layouts display
grid can be used to control multiple
rows and columns at the same time now
css is usually not considered a turing
complete programming language on its own
however it does have mechanisms like
calc to perform mathematical operations
and custom properties which are like
variables that you can reuse in multiple
places vanilla css is rarely enough
though and many developers choose to
extend it with tools like sas that add
additional programmatic features on top
of it and that brings us to the third
language you'll need to know as a web
developer javascript technically you
don't need javascript to build a website
however most developers choose to use it
to make the user interface more
interactive to run javascript code on a
web page open up a script tag then write
some javascript code inside of it the
browser interprets the html from top to
bottom and runs this code when it
encounters it in the dom in most cases
javascript is written in a separate file
then referenced as the source on the
script tag usually it's preferred that
this code runs after the dom content has
loaded which can be accomplished with
the defer attribute js is a big
complicated programming language which
is more formally known as ecmascript and
is standardized in all major browsers
there are several different ways to
declare a variable a variable that might
be reassigned in the future uses the let
keyword while a variable that can't be
reassigned uses const it's a dynamically
typed language which means no type
annotations are necessary that's not
always ideal so many developers choose
typescript as an alternative to add
static typing on top of javascript now
one of the most common reasons you would
use javascript in the first place is to
handle events whenever the user does
something on a web page the browser
emits an event that you can listen to
like a click mouse move form input
change and so on we can tap into these
events using browser apis like document
which in this case provides a method
called query selector that allows us to
grab an element with a css selector once
we have that element set as a variable
we can then assign an event listener to
it an event listener is a function that
will be called or re-executed anytime
the button is clicked the language has a
variety of built-in data structures like
an array to represent a collection of
values but the most fundamental data
structure is the object also commonly
called a dictionary or hashmap anything
that's not a primitive type like a
string or number inherits its base
functionality from the object class it
relies on a technique called prototypal
inheritance where an object can be
cloned multiple times to create a chain
of ancestors where the child inherits
the properties and methods of its
ancestors this is different from
class-based inheritance which is kind of
confusing because javascript also
supports classes however these classes
are just syntactic sugar for prototypal
inheritance but now we're getting a
little too low level most developers
don't ever want to have to touch the
word prototype so what we do instead is
use a front-end framework like react
view spelt angular and so on all of
these frameworks do the same thing in a
slightly different way which is
represent the ui as a tree of components
a component can encapsulate html css and
javascript into a format that looks like
its own custom html element most
importantly they produce declarative
code that describes exactly what the ui
does and that's much easier to work with
than imperative code that you would
normally get with just plain vanilla
javascript at this point we've taken a
look at the frontend stack but now we
need to switch gears to the back end
starting with nodejs which is a
server-side runtime based on javascript
you can run server-side code for web
applications in all kinds of different
languages but node is the most popular
because it relies on the same language
as the browser it's also based on the
same v8 engine that powers the chromium
browser to run code in a single threaded
non-blocking event loop this allows node
to handle many simultaneous connections
quickly and efficiently in addition it
allows developers to share work remotely
thanks to the node package manager a
package is also called a module which is
just a file that contains some code with
an export statement so it can be used in
another file the file can consume a
module with an import statement but now
we need to think about how to deliver
the actual website from the server to
the client the classic option is server
side rendering in this approach the
client will make a get request for a
certain url every request has an http
method and git means you want to
retrieve data from a server as opposed
to methods like post and patch where the
intent is to modify data the server
receives the request and then generates
all the html on the server and sends it
back to the client as a response the
response contains a status code like 200
for success or levels 4 and 500 for
errors for example if the web page
doesn't exist the server will return a
404 status code which you've likely seen
before as a web user ssr is extremely
popular but in some cases it may not be
fast enough another approach is the
single page application with this
approach the server only renders a shell
for the root url then javascript handles
the rendering for all other pages on the
website the html is generated almost
entirely client-side in the browser
making the website feel more like a
native ios or android app when the app
needs more data it still makes an http
request but only requests a minimal
amount of data as json which is called a
data interchange format that can be
understood by any programming language
this can result in a great user
experience however it can be very
difficult for bots like search engines
and social media link previews to
understand content on the page this led
to another rendering strategy called
static site generation in this case
every webpage on the site is uploaded to
a server in advance allowing bots to get
the information they need a front-end
javascript framework usually takes over
to hydrate the html to make it fully
interactive and behave like a single
page application performance is
extremely important and you'll want to
use tools like lighthouse to optimize
metrics like first contentful paint and
time to interactive now to implement one
of these patterns most developers will
use a full stack framework like next js
ruby on rails laravel and so on they
abstract away many of the more tedious
things developers don't want to deal
with one of which is module bundlers
which are tools like webpack and veed
that take all of your javascript css and
html and package it in a way that can
actually work in a browser they might
also provide a linter like eslint to
warn you when your code doesn't follow
the proper style guidelines oh and i
almost forgot you are definitely going
to need a database to build a full stack
web application because you need
somewhere to store your data like data
about your users but in order to get
that data you'll need to give users a
way to log in via a process called user
authentication now before you deploy
your code you'll need to test it with a
web server there are tools like nginx
and apache you create an http server but
your framework will likely do this for
you by serving the files on localhost
which makes your own ip address behave
like a remote web server when it comes
time to deploy you'll likely use a big
cloud provider like aws most apps are
containerized with docker making them
easy to scale up and down based on the
amount of traffic that they receive
there are many tools out there that
function as a platform as a service to
manage this infrastructure for you in
exchange for your money or if you don't
want to get locked in with a giant tech
corporation you might host your app on a
decentralized blockchain with web3 and
that's about one percent of what you'll
need to know to call yourself a full
stack web developer if that seems
overwhelming don't worry too much almost
nobody knows what the hell they're doing
and we all just use google to figure
things out on the fly congratulations
you just passed web development 101
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one